and on that front that's how I bring in
one of our favorite guests here who has
been on this program before the red-hot
show West world on HBO
every single Sunday night at 9:00
Eastern Time season three has been going
on for a month Plus now and he is a man
who has put together a GoFundMe page to
feed health care workers in the great
borough of Brooklyn New York during this
pandemic he is none other than Jeffrey
Wright how are you sir I'm doing all
right
rich maintained and maintained in here
in Brooklyn how are you I am doing fine
we're maintaining here and in Los
Angeles California what we know what
brought this on but why why why is this
necessary in your world this GoFundMe
page Jeffrey well you know I live in
Brooklyn I love my neighborhood I live
in Fort Greene section of Brooklyn and
one of the things that defined is the
places where we gather we've got cars of
course and we have restaurants which
really define culture for us here define
the character of our neighborhood and
they're places where we come together
when we live we live together so I
happen to have a couple of friends who
own a couple of spots here and one of
them was not a delivery oriented
business and so we anticipated that we
were going on lockdown he was trying to
shift over to a delivery mode and I said
okay you do that I'll amp you up on on
Twitter see if you get you know some
good business going I called him up the
next day I said Mike team members
Michael Thompson he's over at a place
called the Brooklyn moon I said Mike how
did you do today he said man I got five
orders I'm like oh boy that's not gonna
work so uh so I got pinged on Twitter
that another friend a guy named Vito
Randazzo over the place called
graziella's
great Pete said great lasagna in the
whole work that he had been having
customers calling to order pizzas on
behalf of Brooklyn Hospital which is in
our neighborhood in fact I'm looking at
it right now as I look out the window so
I be south to Vito
I said hey put me in touch with the
hospital I want to see what's going on
over there he did got in Lenny
Singletary VP external affairs
credible guy on the front line he said
you know in fact we could use more meals
because we have people working 15 15
hour days they're not going home summer
you know sleeping in hotels the
paramedics around here sleeping in their
cars they need meals what can you do
so we ended up putting together March 27
was our first hit 200 meals we started
off with 100 but because Vito had
already ordered delivered a couple
pizzas so we started off really with a
hundred meals March 27 to Portland
Hospital to restaurants working since
then we've grown to 38 restaurant
writing 2,500 meals per day on average
we just crossed the $35,000 meal 35,000
meal mark and we we're serving I believe
now six hospitals in Brooklyn one in
lower Manhattan all 10 EMS and Terra EMS
station in Brooklyn and we just added
today I believe we as of tomorrow will
be delivering to seventh Hospital in
Brooklyn so we're keeping you know these
restaurants let's keep their their ovens
hot keeping them afloat through hard
time and getting some food to these
frontline workers who you know who have
other things to concern themselves with
as opposed to where they're going to
find their next meal and first
responders to almost $200,000 you've
raised on your GoFundMe page Jeffrey
right and all you need to do to to add
dollars and cents to this great cause is
go to the GoFundMe homepage and search
Brooklyn for life or go to the Instagram
page of Jeffrey Wright at J free right
and hit that link right there that we
posted up you can go to Brooklyn for
life.org there's a donate button there
to lead you to the GoFundMe page that's
if that's easier - Jeffrey how is it
rudimentary you don't have people in
West world helping you out I mean you
can I mean that's some of my text up
there right there
I bet I bet Jeffrey right here on the
Rich Eisen show let's talk a little
football um your your Washington
Redskins sitting second overall on on
the clock right here it looks like chase
young from Ohio State's coming your way
do you like the changes that Washington
has made with Ron Rivera and everything
going on Jeffery rich rich rich such a
long conversation you know change is
good there but there I'm not sure if all
of the necessary change has been made I
think these guys you have a great
opportunity I'm just concerned about I'm
just concerned about the general culture
of the organization frankly yeah you
know me we've exchanged that's about
this it's been it's been decades now you
know the same story we're gonna make
some adjustments and then we you know we
come up with the same disappointment not
saying that you know I'm not trying to
project that on now but I don't know I
mean we used to be some Washington used
to be you know a big benchmark franchise
in in FL I mean we were Kings baby and
it's been 25 years of disappointment
it's been 25 years of a kind of you know
miserable fan unfriendly experience at
that Stadium I've only been there twice
since they left
RFK my mom was a season ticket holder at
RFK from 1970 she passed away last fall
she was a season ticket holder at the
new place but I you know up until the
end but I can't bring myself to go there
it's just it's just rich I just you know
know I I know I know you want to go I
know you want to go further up the flow
chart I know you want to go further up
the flow chart but let me just say this
Ron Rivera is a different higher than
any of the hires that I think this
organization has made I
I dig him I like him and I think I think
you're gonna like him too
serious guy no there's no question about
it he's you know he's all business but I
do wonder when I look at you know the
the the choices that we've made I wonder
how we let a guy like Shaun Vegas you
know he was paper what seven eight
season how do you not recognize that
that guy had something special going on
obviously the Shanahan situation was
complicated with Kyle and his dad but
you know there's been a lot of
extraordinary you know young talent
that's come through their innovative
talent that's come through their I do
wonder how those guys you know we're
allowed to step off the you know out of
the frame on some organizations were
they've had extraordinary success I
makes me wonder what's going on in terms
of decision made
Jeffrey right here on the Rich Eisen
show the the last dance documentary of
Jordans coming out on ESPN over the
weekend do you have any memories of
those arrows and obviously we all know
where Michael finished up in your in
your hometown of Washington DC do you
have any thoughts on that subject
Jeffrey right well one of the most
magnificent athletes that that has ever
been produced in the world and so I look
forward to checking that out you know he
just had such a he was such a beautiful
athlete he just handy and you know his
fierceness which he passed down to to
Kobe I mean he was he didn't know their
their are their arguments about who was
you know you know who's the greatest
ever for me you know you can't be Jordan
I mean Jordan recreated the game and he
had a desire to win he had a character
about him on that on that court that few
others can approach in any other sport
so yeah I look for seeing a but of
course you know yeah I'm from DC I was a
bullet guy you know now were the wizard
but I'm in Brooklyn now so I gotta say
I'm uh you know I'm Brooklyn
oh yeah you know of course you know
Durant and obviously Durant and Kyrie
when they get healthy and and the same
way you feel or at least I picked up
the sense of the way you feel about the
owner of your football team I feel
similarly about the owner of the New
York knickerbockers and the nets the
nets of the team in New York City now
that's a period and a story statement
Jeffrey there's no denying that know
about it and you know around KD and
Kyrie you know when they when they come
back in full health got a great group of
young players there they show that the
previous seasons they were showing that
this team's and you know I want to see
them I've been working on Batman over in
London just beginning of January so I
missed a bunch of games but I you know I
got tickets over there and I I wouldn't
see them that's when the Lakers came to
town and I said you know what these guys
you beat the Lakers I'm watching it I'm
seeing but it seems like you know we may
have read a few too many newspaper
clippings here and the Lakers of course
are incredibly talented and also massive
on the court massive presence but they
were getting into head to you know you
had a Dwight Howard like clearing and
growling you know I mean they it was
really with a lot of hit games being
being being played but you saw I saw
that you know we have challenges to keep
up with him and yet you cut you you know
one of the final games of the shortened
season and you know they got and that's
got him you know the Nets have a lot
going on it I look forward to to you
know when we start playing basketball
again to see it all come together it's
gonna be yeah before I let you go
Jeffery you mentioned the Batman you are
playing Commissioner Gordon in the
Batman which is out next year once again
you're playing the role of Felix Leiter
in James Bond and no time to die but
hits theaters coming up later on this
fall as kovat 19 and bows moved the date
of that all day and night available on
Netflix coming up on the 1st of May the
French dispatch out in October
Janu West Anderson film but I do want to
just hit you about Westworld blue my god
I mean that was that was a very long
list of just what's going on I just so
excited about what's happening with your
career in Westworld is just as hot as
ever and the reason for that I think is
Marshawn Lynch join the cast this
would you not agree Jeffrey 100 did you
cross paths with them on the set at any
point Oh
put yourself in beast mode no question
because we didn't have we don't interact
I'll say spoiler alert yes we were you
know we shoot two three units at a time
on any given day sure so the first day
we were on set at the same time they
were like okay Jeffrey that you need
your what no beats motors here I'm gonna
have to wait till I have to go over and
just meet him say hello man and he was
it's a great a great great food and
great character really open really
loving being on set with it and then you
know cut you what two months later he's
back on the field that's right you know
a cast mate who later went on to I don't
know if you're where Jeffrey you might
not be where I think Anthony Hopkins did
it the year before I'm sorry that was
Silence of the Lambs he did it two
decades ago my dad he was the first
beast mode I believe it's Hannibal
Lecter if I'm not mistaken
Jeffrey great chat again everybody
should search Brooklyn for life when you
go to the go fund me page and join what
has just been a beautiful seed growing
in Brooklyn a tree planted in Brooklyn
as we all know is such an important
beautiful thing GoFundMe page to feed
health care workers and emergency
service members in Brooklyn and in the
city of New York during this pandemic
thanks for joining me
Jeffrey you're welcome here anytime
right back at you that's Jeffrey right
at J free right on both Twitter and
Instagram
kram hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here